maligayang pagbabalik sa Quantum Computing sa Praktika ako si Olivia Lanes at ang episode tatlo ngayon ay magtutuon sa isang
qaoa experiment sa utility scale kung kasama ka sa amin mula pa sa simula ay nakita mo na nating talakayin
ang IBM Quantum Hardware ang framework ng Qiskit patterns at ang pinakabago at pinakamahusay na error mitigation techniques na
ginagamit ng mga mananaliksik at developer para mag-scale up ng Quantum circuits naramdaman namin na talagang mahalaga na ibigay sa inyo ang lahat ng ito
konteksto at ipakita sa inyo ang direksyon na patungo tayo ngunit ngayon ay wala nang dahilan para maghintay pa para makita ang lahat ng impormasyong ito sa
aksyon ngayon ang ilang mga bagay na dapat tandaan bago tayo magsimula lahat ay susunod sa framework ng Qiskit
patterns kaya dadaan tayo sa mga hakbang na ito sa pagkakasunod-sunod numero isa ay ang pag-map ng problema dalawa ang pag-optimize ng circuit tatlo
ang pag-execute gamit ang Primitives at apat ang postprocessing o pagsusuri ng mga resulta magsisimula tayo sa isang medyo maliit na halimbawa
para lahat kayo ay makahanap ng pinakamahusay na kahulugan ng mga hakbang na ito at ang kanilang layunin pagkatapos ay tatalakayin natin ang isang halos kapareho ngunit mas
malaking halimbawa para ipakita kung paano mag-scale up ng problema sa 100 qubit na antas ibibigay ko sa inyo ang lahat ng
mga tool para hayaan kayong sumulong pagkatapos ng lekturang ito at patakbuhin ang problemang iyon nang nagsasarili sa wakas ay hindi ito
magiging isang code walkthrough gaano man nating subukan habang nagagawa natin ang pag-unlad ang code ay nagiging luma at napag-iwanaan kaya kung magtatapos ka
na panoorin ang video na ito isang taon pagkatapos nitong ilunsad ay hindi ko gusto na matigil ka sa syntax na maaaring kaunting magbago sa paglipas ng panahon sa halip ito ay magiging isang
detalyadong talakayan ng lohika at ng pahayag ng problema gayunpaman mayroon isang notebook tutorial na nagmamatch sa
video na ito na nakalakip sa description sa ibaba ang pagsunod sa code o pag-refer dito pagkatapos mong
panoorin ang araling ito at patakbuhin ito para sa iyong sarili ay magbibigay sa iyo ng pinakamahusay na posibleng karanasan sa pagkatuto kaya bilang mabilis na paalala hindi
lahat ng computational problem ay angkop para sa Quantum Computing ang mga madaling problema at simpleng kalkulasyon ay hindi kailangang
samantalahin ang teknolohiyang ito dahil ang mga classical computer ay perpektong mabuti sa paglutas ng mga ito na ngayon ng 2024 ang
tatlong larangan na pinaka-optimistiko tayo sa pag-explore ay ang mga ito ang pag-simulate ng kalikasan ang pagproseso ng data na may kumplikadong
istruktura at sa wakas ang optimization ang mga optimization problem ay ilan sa mga pinakamahirap na computational
problema para malutas nang mahusay sa isang optimization problem ay naghahanap ka ng pinakamalaki o pinakamaliit na posibleng halaga
para sa isang ibinigay na cost function gayunpaman para sa maraming problema ng Interes ang paghanap ng extremum na ito ay nagiging exponential na mas
mahirap sa sukat ng problema iyon ang dahilan kung bakit ito ay nagiging napakahirap na i-compute para sa isang halimbawa maaari mong isipin kung gaano
kahirap na kalkulahin ang mga optimal na flight path o delivery route sa buong bansa sa araling ito ay
tuklasin natin ang isang partikular na optimization problem na tinatawag na Max Cut na malulutas natin sa pamamagitan ng paggamit ng isang Quantum
algorithm na tinatawag na quantum approximation optimization algorithm o qaoa kaya ano ang max cut problem ang isang
maximum cut problem ay isang uri ng combinatorial optimization problem na tinukoy sa isang graph kung saan ang layunin ay
hatiin ang mga vertex ng graph sa dalawang subset na ang bilang ng mga gilid sa pagitan ng dalawang subset ay
maximized kaya halimbawa sa graph na ito dito ang bawat node ay konektado tulad nito at ang max cut ay ipinapakita ng squiggly
linya na ito na humahatid sa mga node sa purple na grupo at sa gray na grupo ang paraan ng paggawa nito sa pamamagitan ng pagdaan sa pinakamalaking
bilang ng mga posibleng gilid ay ang putulin ang limang gilid para sa graph na ito dito dahil ang graph ay napakaliit
ay hindi mahirap na subukan ang ilang posibleng cut sa papel o kahit sa iyong isipan at alamin na ang lima ay ang pinakamahusay na posibleng
pagpipilian ngunit isipin kung ang bilang ng mga node ay domoble at pagkatapos ay triple mabilis itong nagiging imposible na gawin nang
kamay at pagkatapos ng isang tiyak na bilang ito ay nagiging napakamahirap na kahit ang mga supercomputer ay nahihirapang maibalik ang pinakamahusay na sagot ito ay dahil
ang max na bilang ng mga cut ay nagsasala nang exponentially kasama ang bilang ng mga node habang ang ito ay maaaring kaunting abstract
mayroon maraming mga real world na problema na maaaring ilagay sa isang Max cut problem tulad ng fraud detection sa pananalapi graph
clustering network design at VLSI design pati na rin ang social media analysis ang
social media ay partikular na madaling maunawaan sabihin nating gusto mong mahanap ang isang grupo ng mga indibidwal na may pinakamaraming posibleng
koneksyon sa iba pang mga indibidwal sa isang social media platform para matukoy ang mga power user o mga taong may
pinakamaraming impluwensya sa isang grupo ang mga kumpanya ay talagang subukan na gawin ito nang madalas isang huling punto dito ang max cut ay madalas
isang subroutine ng isang mas malaking problema kaya maaaring hindi ito nagtatakda ng aktwal na aplikasyon ngunit ginagamit sa ilalim ng kapote ito ay
mas karaniwan kaysa sa maaari mong simpleng isipin ngayon ay oras na para magsimula ang
unang hakbang ay lumikha ng ating graph maaari mong gawin ito sa pamamagitan ng pag-import ng isang python package na tinatawag na rustworkx tukuyin kung gaano
karaming mga node ang iyong ginagawa sa pamamagitan ng pagtukoy ng bilang n pagkatapos ay idagdag ang iyong mga node sa graph G kakailanganin mo rin
na iguhit ang iyong mga gilid gagawin natin ito nang kamay dito sa pamamagitan ng paglalagay lamang ng mga ito sa isang array tulad nito kung saan ipinakita mo ang huli
na numero na nagtutukoy ng timbang ng gilid o kung gaano kalakas ang dalawang node na tinukoy ay nakakonekta dito ay manatili tayo
sa isang timbang para sa lahat ngunit maaari kang mag-enjoy sa paglaro ng timbang sa ibang pagkakataon at makita kung paano nagbabago ang solusyon
para makakuha ng kaunting kahulugan ng ibig sabihin ng timbang sa kontekstong ito bumalik tayo sa ating social media na halimbawa maaari mong isipin
ng timbang na ito bilang kung gaano kaimpluwensya ang isang tao sa isa pa ang iyong koneksyon sa iyong asawa o kamag-anak
halimbawa ay malamang na bibigyan ng mas mataas na timbang kaysa sa isang taong kakilala mo lamang ngayon iguhit ang iyong graph ang
tutorial na nakalakip ay magpapakita sa iyo ng tamang syntax una bago isaalang-alang kung paano
i-map ang problemang ito sa isang Quantum circuit buuin natin ang ilang konteksto kung paano nagiging optimization problem ang max cut problem
sa unang lugar Nagsisimula tayo sa pamamagitan ng una ay isaalang-alang ang minimization ng isang function f ng x kung saan ang input X ay isang
n-dimensional na vector na ang mga component ay katumbas ng bawat node ng graph irefer natin ang function na ito mula ngayon
bilang ang aming cost function pagkatapos ay kailangan nating i-constrain ang bawat isa sa mga component na ito para maging alinman sa zero o
isa dito ibig sabihin ay nasa isang panig ng cut o sa isa pa maaari tayong sumulat ng isang function bilang
isang pares ng mga node x i at xj na nagsasabi sa atin kung ang kaugnay na gilid ay nasa cut kaya plus ang dami na x i + xj
minus x i xj ay nagpapakilala kung ang gilid ay nasa cut kung ang dami na ito ay katumbas
ng isa ay nangangahulugang ang gilid ay nasa cut kung hindi ay zero at ang gilid ay wala ang problema ng paghahanap ng
max na bilang ng mga gilid sa cut ay maaaring i-formulate bilang maximizing ng function na ito susunod ay talagang magdadagdag tayo ng isang global minus sign sa function na ito na ginagawang katumbas ang bagong problema sa paghahanap ng minimum ng function na ito
sa halip at kaya ang minimum ng f ng x sa kasong ito ay magiging kapag ang bilang ng mga gilid na dinadaanan ng cut ay
maximal pinipili naming i-frame ang problemang ito bilang isang minimization problem dahil nagbibigay-daan ito sa atin na sa kalaunan ay i-map ito sa isang energy
minimization problem AKA ang paghahanap ng ground state na siyong natural na pinakamahusay na ginagawa ng mga quantum computer
ngunit tandaan na wala pang kaugnay sa Quantum Computing dito kailangan pa nating i-reformulate ang problemang ito sa
isang bagay na mauunawaan ng isang quantum computer handa na tayong tukin ang ngipin natin at simulan ang gawain at ang
unang hakbang ay ang i-map ang problema sa isang Quantum circuit maaaring hindi halata kung paano tayo
pupunta mula sa isang graph tulad ng isa na kagaguhit lamang natin patungo sa isang Quantum circuit ngunit dahan-dahang gawin natin ito tandaan na
susubukan nating lutasin ang Max cut problem na ito gamit ang qaoa sa qaoa algorithm ay gugustuhin nating magkaroon ng isang operator
ang hamiltonian na gagamitin para kumatawan ng cost function ng ating problema pati na rin ang isang parameterized
circuit ang ansatz o ang trial state na gagamitin natin para kumatawan ng mga Quantum state na mga educated guess o mga kandidato
para sa solusyon ng problema maaari tayong mag-sample mula sa mga kandidatong estado na ito at pagkatapos ay suriin ang mga ito
gamit ang cost function sa kasong ito ang cost function ay f ng x ngunit kailangan nating ipahayag ito sa isang
paraan na natural sa quantum computer para dito ay sinasamantala natin ang isang serye ng mga matematikal
na transformation para ipahayag ang f ng x bilang isang energy function ang hamiltonian ang unang hakbang ng
proseso ay ipahayag ang problema ng minimizing ng f ng x bilang isang quadratic unconstrained binary optimization
problem o QUBO para maikli ang QUBO ay isang pangkalahatang paraan ng pag-formulate ng mga combinatorial optimization problem
dito ang Q ay isang N by N Matrix ng mga real number ang N ay katumbas ng bilang ng
mga node sa ating graph lima para sa halimbawang ito at ang X ay ang parehong vector ng mga binary variable mula sa paunang
formulation para epektibong patakbuhin ang qaoa algorithm kailangan nating ipahayag ang ating optimization problem sa mga tuntunin ng isang
hamiltonian na siyang isang matematikal na operator na kumakatawan sa kabuuang enerhiya ng isang sistema tiyak na gusto
nating lumikha ng isang cost function hamiltonian na may katangian na ang ground state energy o minimum na eigenvalue nito
ay katumbas ng minimum ng function na nag-e-encode ng maximum na bilang ng mga cut sa graph g kapag mayroon na
tayong hamiltonian na ito ang kailangan lang nating gawin para malutas ang ating optimization problem ay ihanda ang ground state ng hamiltonian sa quantum computer pagkatapos
ang pag-sample mula sa estadong ito ay magbubunga nang may mataas na posibilidad ng solusyon sa minimization ng f ng X tulad ng
nangyayari ay maswerte tayo dahil ang QUBO problem ay malapit na kaugnay at talagang computationally equivalent sa
isa sa mga pinakasikat at ubiquitous na hamiltonian sa physics ang Ising hamiltonian para isulat ang QUBO
problem bilang Ising hamiltonian ang kailangan lang nating gawin ay isang simpleng pagbabago ng variable para lumipat mula sa
mga Boolean variable 0 at 1 sa mga spin variable na minus isa at isa ang hakbang na ito ay
tapat ipinapakita ito nang mas detalyado sa appendix ng nakalakip na notebook para sa mga interesado ngunit sa huli ang minimization ng QUBO
expression ay kapareho ng minimization ng ekspresyong ito muling isinusulat nang kaunti at
mayroon na tayong cost function hamiltonian kung saan ang minimum ng ekspresyon ay kumakatawan sa ground state at ang Z
ay nagiging ang Pauli Z operator habang ang B ay isang real scalar coefficient ngayon na mayroon na tayo ng ating
hamiltonian ay tapat na muling isulat ito sa mga tuntunin ng dalawang local ZZ Pauli operator na madaling mag-convert sa
dalawang qubit gate sa ating Quantum circuit pakitingnan ang kaugnay na notebook para makita kung paano ito ginagawa ngunit ang output
ay ibinibigay ng linya na ito dito tandaan na sa ating halimbawa ay mayroon
anim na mga object o Pauli string dahil ang bawat isa ay kumakatawan sa isang gilid sa graph ang haba ng string ay tumutugma sa bilang ng
mga node kaya ang i i i ZZ ay limang node at ang string ay binubuo ng
mga identity sa lahat ng posisyon maliban sa mga index ng mga node na kasangkot sa isang gilid na magkakaroon ng mga Z term sa Qiskit
ang mga bit string na kumakatawan ng mga qubit ay naka-index nang baligtad halimbawa ang isang gilid sa pagitan ng mga node 0 at 1 ay ine-encode bilang
I I I ZZ na may hamiltonian na nasusulat sa mga tuntunin ng mga Pauli handa na tayong itayo ang aming
Quantum circuit ang Quantum circuit na ito ay makakatulong sa ating mag-sample ng magagandang solusyon mula sa quantum computer ang qaoa algorithm
ay inspirado mula sa adiabatic theorem na nagsasabing kung nagsisimula tayo sa ground state ng time dependent
hamiltonian at kung ang hamiltonian ay mabagal na nag-evolve at binigyan ng sapat na oras ang huling estado ay magiging ang ground
state ng huling hamiltonian ang qaoa ay maaaring isipin bilang ang discrete Trotter bersyon ng quantum
adiabatic algorithm kung saan ang bawat Trotter step ay kumakatawan sa isang layer na tatawagin nating P kaya
sa halip na mag-evolve mula sa isang estado patungo sa isa pa sa bawat layer ng P ay lilipat tayo nang pabalik-balik sa pagitan ng ating cost
function hamiltonian at isang tinatawag na ating mixer hamiltonian na maririnig natin nang higit pa tungkol doon sa lalong madaling panahon ngunit ang punto na gusto kong gawin
ay ang qaoa ay may kalamangan na mas mabilis kaysa sa quantum adiabatic algorithm ngunit nagbabalik ito ng approximate
na mga solusyon sa halip na ang pinakamainam sa limitasyon kung saan ang bilang ng mga layer ay pumunta sa Infinity ang qaoa ay nagkukumpleto sa adiabatic
na kaso ngunit siyempre ito ay napaka-expensive na computationally para lumikha ng ating Quantum circuit
ay mag-a-apply tayo ng alternating operators dito na parameterized ng gamma at beta na
kumakatawan sa discretization ng time evolution kaya muli ang tatlong pangunahing bahagi
ng qaoa circuit ay isa ang paunang trial state sa Gray na siyong ground
state ng mixer mula sa adiabatic state ng ebolusyon na nilikha sa pamamagitan ng pag-apply ng isang Hadamard gate na inilapat sa bawat qubit dalawa
ang cost function evolution na mayroon na tayo sa dark purple at tatlo ang ebolusyon sa ilalim ng mixer
hamiltonian na hindi pa natin tinalakay sa light purple ngayon ang ating panimulang hamiltonian ay
tinatawag na mixer dahil ang ground state nito ay ang superposition ng lahat ng posibleng bit string ng Interes kaya
nagpapatupad ng pinagsamang lahat ng posibleng solusyon sa simula ang mixer hamiltonian ay ang simpleng kabuuan ng Pauli X
operations sa bawat node ng graph pinapayagan ka ng Qiskit na gumamit ng iba't ibang custom mixer operator kung gusto mo ngunit
para sa kasong ito ay gagamit tayo ng pamantayan kaya muli ay makikita mo na sa Qiskit marami sa gawain ay
inaalis para sa atin na ginagawang trivial ang pagkuha ng mixer hamiltonian at ang panimulang estado ang tanging gawain na kailangan nating gawin ay
ang mahanap ang cost function ang bawat iteration ng mga operator na ito ay tinatawag na isang layer ang mga layer na ito ay maaaring makita bilang
mga discretization ng time evolution ng sistema tulad ng naipahayag nang dati ang alternating pattern ay nagmumula sa
Trotter decomposition at nagpapalapit sa mga exponential function ng mga non-commuting matrices sa pangkalahatan mas maraming layer o
hakbang ang aming isasama mas malapit tayo sa continuous time evolution kaya sa teorya mas tumpak ang resulta
ngunit para sa halimbawang ito ay magsisimula tayo sa pamamagitan lamang ng pag-sample gamit ang dalawang layer tandaan na ang parehong cost function hamiltonian at
ang mixer ay parameterized kailangan pa nating makagawa ng pinakamainam na mga halaga para sa gamma at
beta ngayon ay nakilala ko na iyon ay maraming impormasyon at kung nakikita mo ang ganitong uri ng matematika sa unang pagkakataon ay maaaring ito ay mahirap sa kabutihang palad ang isa sa mga kahanga-hangang
bagay tungkol sa Qiskit ay ang marami sa aming tinalakay nang dati ay maaaring gawin nang awtomatiko nang walang malaking pagsisikap mula sa user maganda na maunawaan kung ano ang
nangyayari sa ilalim ng kapote lalo na habang nagsu-scale up tayo sa mas malalaking eksperimento ngunit hindi mo kailangang gawin ang lahat ng gawaing ito nang
kamay sa bawat oras na-map na natin ang ating problema sa isang Quantum circuit ito ay medyo gawain
ngunit huwag mag-alala nagiging mas madali at mas intuitive habang mas maraming beses mong ginagawa ito ngayon ay handa na tayong lumipat sa hakbang dalawa
pag-optimize ng aming circuit para sa Hardware kaya habang ang circuit na kagagawa lamang natin ay mukhang medyo simple at
kapaki-pakinabang para buuin ang isang intuitive na pag-unawa tandaan na ang quantum chip ay hindi nakakaunawa kung ano ang abstracted
bloke na ito kailangan nating gawing ito sa isang serye ng isa at dalawang qubit gate na native sa hardware at kapag
sinabing native ibig sabihin ay ito ay muling i-factor sa kung ano ang maaaring direktang isagawa sa mga qubit ang mga ganitong circuit ay
sinasabing nasusulat sa instruction set architecture ng backend na maaaring makita mong pinaikli bilang ISA circuits
ang Qiskit SDK transpiler module ay nag-aalok ng isang serye ng mga transpilation pass na maaaring
magsagawa ng malawak na hanay ng mga circuit transformation gusto nating matiyak na ang aming circuit ay na-optimize para sa aming
layunin alalahanin mula sa aming nakaraang aralin na ang transpilation at proseso ay nagsasangkot ng ilang mga hakbang ang pag-map ng
mga qubit sa circuit o ang mga decision variable sa mga pisikal na qubit sa device ang pag-unroll ng mga instruksyon sa
quantum circuit sa mga hardware native na instruksyon na talagang naiintindihan ng backend ang routing ng anumang
mga qubit sa circuit na direktang nagkikipag-interaksyon sa mga pisikal na qubit na magkakatabi sa isa't
isa at tulad ng palagi ay mas maraming detalye ang matatagpuan sa dokumentasyon
site ngayon ay darating ang isang kapana-panabik na hakbang kung saan pipiliin natin kung aling backend ang patatakabuhin ng ating circuit talagang kailangan nating gawin ito
bago ang transpilation step dahil ang transpiler ay nag-o-optimize nang naiiba para sa iba't ibang processor ito ay isa pa sa mga dahilan kung bakit ito ay
mahalaga na ma-automate ng Qiskit ang napakaraming bahagi ng yugtong ito hindi mo gustong i-optimize ang iyong circuit nang kamay
na magagawa ngunit minsan ito ay mahirap at napaka-tumatagal lamang para mapagtanto na gusto mo talagang patakbuhin ang
iyong circuit sa ibang processor na may iba't ibang katangian at pagkatapos ay kailangan mong gawin ulit ang lahat ng trabahong iyon ipasa ang
iyong backend ng pagpipilian sa pamamagitan ng transpiler function at huwag kalimutang tukuyin ang iyong optimization level sa
pagkakataong ito ay pinili ko ang optimization level tatlo na siyang pinakamataas at pinaka-exhaustive optimization
level at iyon na talaga para sa hakbang dalawa ang aking circuit ay na-transpile nang awtomatiko at iginuhit ko ito dito para
makita mo kung paano ito isinalin sa isa at dalawang qubit gate ngayon ay oras na para sa hakbang tatlo
ang pagpapatakbo ng circuit gamit ang Qiskit Primitives hanggang ngayon ay na-transpile natin ang circuit na nag-iiwan ng mga parameter na gamma at
beta nang mag-isa ngunit talagang hindi natin maaaring patakbuhin ang circuit nang hindi tinukoy ang halaga ng mga parameter na ito sa qaoa
workflow ang mga optimal na qaoa parameter ay matatagpuan sa isang iterative optimization loop kung saan nagpapatakbo tayo ng isang serye ng circuit
evaluations at gumagamit ng isang classical optimizer para mahanap ang mga optimal na beta at gamma na parameter gayunpaman kailangan nating magsimula
kung saan kaya nagsagawa ako ng ilang paunang hula para sa Gamma 1 gamma 2 at beta 1 beta 2 ng Pi / 2 at Pi
ayon sa pagkakasunod Nais ko rin na pansinin mo na gagamit tayo ng isang optimizer para makahanap ng mas magandang mga solusyon para sa gamma at Beta
at dahil dalawang layer lang ang kinakalkula ko sa ngayon iyon lang ang kailangan ko ngunit kung gagawa ka ng mas tumpak na qaoa circuit
ay isasama mo ang mas maraming layer at kaya nangangailangan ng isang optimized na gamma at beta para sa bawat sunod-sunod
na layer ngayon ay kumuha muna ng isang minuto dito para huminto at alalahanin ang ating mga pagpipilian para sa Primitives mayroon tayo ng estimator at
ang sampler alin sa tingin mo ang gagamitin natin para sa ganitong uri ng trabaho nang hindi alintana kung alin ang iyong
hinula ay talagang tama ka gagamitin natin ang parehong estimator at sampler para sa paunang optimization
loop kakailanganin natin ang estimator ngunit gagamitin natin ang sampler sa ibang pagkakataon para sa pagbabasa ng huling
solusyon ngayon ay halos handa na tayong patakbuhin ang ating algorithm nangangako ako ngunit napaka-mabilis mahalaga na pansinin na maaari kang
magpadala ng iyong trabaho sa iba't ibang paraan na tinatawag na mga execution mode una ay mayroon tayong job mode isang solong
primitive request ng estimator o sampler na ginawa nang walang isang context manager ang mga circuit at input ay naka-package bilang primitive
unified blocks o pubs at isinumite bilang isang execution task sa quantum
computer ang batch mode ay isang multi-job manager para sa mahusay na pagpapatakbo ng isang eksperimento na binubuo ng isang bungkos
ng mga independent na trabaho gamitin ang batch mode para magsumite ng maraming primitive job nang sabay-sabay ang session mode ay isang dedicated
window para sa pagpapatakbo ng isang multi-job workload nagbibigay-daan ito sa mga premium user na mag-eksperimento sa mga variational algorithm sa mas
predictable na paraan at kahit magpatakbo ng maraming eksperimento nang sabay-sabay na sinasamantala ang parallelism ng
stack gamitin ang mga session para sa mga iterative workflow at mga eksperimento na nangangailangan ng dedicated na access para sa isang qaoa experiment ang isang
session ay magiging magandang pagpipilian para sumulong kung mayroon kang access dito dahil kailangan mong subukan ang maraming circuit para sa iba't ibang halaga ng beta
at gamma okay ngayon ay bumalik tayo sa ating optimization problem na tukoy na natin ang
cost function hamiltonian HC at ang buong workflow ay ito ang qaoa
algorithm ay nagsisimula sa pamamagitan ng pagsisimula ng mga qubit sa superposition state at pagkatapos ay nag-a-apply ng ansatz na may P layers
sinisimulan ang mga gamma at beta parameter at pagkatapos ay pinapatakbo ang circuit gamit ang estimator primitive kapag nakalkula na natin ang
mga expectation value ay gagamit na tayo ng isang scipy optimizer na tinatawag na COBYLA ang COBYLA
ay nag-o-optimize ng cost function nang classical sa labas ng qpu kapag na-update na ang mga halagang iyon ng gamma at beta
uulitin natin ito hanggang sa converge na ang halaga ng pangkalahatang cost function at maabot ang pinakamababang halaga
pagkatapos ay pipiliin natin ang mga halaga ng gamma at beta na katumbas ng mababang halaga ng cost at patatakabuhin ang circuit nang isa pa
pagkatapos ay pipiliin natin ang mga halaga ng gamma at beta na katumbas ng mababang halaga ng cost at patatakabuhin ang circuit nang isa pang
beses ngayon gamit ang sampler ito ang resulta ng pagpapatakbo ko ng COBYLA optimizer sa aking mga paunang hula dito makikita mo
na ang halaga ng cost function sa mga iteration na isasagawa ay nagsisimula nang kaunti pabago-bago at pataas at pababa ngunit
pagkatapos ay nagtatayo sa isang mababang halaga gagamitin natin ang mga huling gamma at beta na halaga na katumbas ng minimum cost
function evaluation para patakbuhin ang circuit nang isa pang beses at i-sample ang bit string na magbibigay sa atin ng max
cut ngayon gamit ang aming mga na-optimize na halaga para sa mga gamma at beta ay patatakabuhin natin ang circuit nang isa pang beses para mahanap ang pinakamahusay
posibleng bit string gamit ang sampler inilista ko ang mga tiyak na halaga na ginagamit ko dito ngunit tandaan kapag sinubukan mo ito
o kahit muling patakbuhin ang parehong tutorial notebook ang mga halagang ito ay maaaring kaunting magbago ngayon ay patatakabuhin natin ang
aming na-optimize na circuit na may mga halagang ito at hanapin ang aming kandidatong solusyon sa aming Max cut problem kung ginagamit mo ang
mga session ay hindi na iyon kinakailangan dahil nagpapatakbo lang tayo ng isang huling trabaho ngayon ay titingnan na natin ang
postprocessing stage at paghanap ng aming huling solusyon una ay i-plot natin ang lahat ng
posibleng kombinasyon ng mga node na aming na-convert sa mga bit string bilang isang histogram maaari mong makita agad na
nang patakbuhin ko ay nahanap ko ang apat na solusyon at itinatampok ang mga iyon sa purple na mas malamang kaysa sa anumang ibang solusyon
ang pinakamataas at kaya pinaka-malamang na bit string na solusyon ay 0 1 01 pakipansin ang pagkakasunod-sunod ng mga qubit
ay baligtad sa plot na naghahanap sa pinaka-malamang na solusyon ay mapapansin natin na ang mga node 0 at tatlo ay magkasamang naka-grupo
at gayundin para sa mga node 1 2 at apat maaari na nating i-plot ang pinaka-malamang
na bit string pabalik bilang isang graph at tandaan na ang bit string ay simpleng katumbas ng mga numero ng node at kung sila ay kasama
na may markang isa o hindi kasama na may markang zero sa aming grupo kapag ginuhit na natin ang cut ngayon makikita natin gamit ang ating mga mata ang
approximate na linya para sa pinakamahusay na cut na simpleng kumakatawan sa ideal na pag-grupo ng lahat ng limang node na iginuhit ko dito isang
bagay na gusto ko na gumastos ng ilang oras na talakayin dito gayunpaman ay ang katotohanan na ang tamang solusyon ay hindi natatangi
dahil sa symmetry ng graph na ito ay mayroon maraming tamang solusyon sa halip na magkaroon ng mga node 0 at tatlo
sa loob ng cut maaari tayong magkaroon ng mga node 2 at apat na kasama at makikita mo na ang kailangan ko lang gawin ay i-rotate ang aking cut para
isama ang mga bagong puntong ito ang solusyong ito ng lima ay nananatiling pareho
tingnan nating muli ang histogram at ang apat na pinaka-malamang na solusyon sa isang minuto ang dalawang huling solusyon ay ang
mga kagaguhit lang natin at pantay-pantay silang tama ngunit hindi iyon lahat maaari din nating baligtarin ang pagkulay para sa lahat
ng mga tamang solusyon at sa pagkakataong ito ay iniisip na lang natin ang mga node bilang nasa loob versus sa labas ng cut sa
nakaraang slide natukoy namin ang dalawang natatanging tamang solusyon ngunit talagang mayroon pang dalawang solusyon na isa na katumbas ng
kabaligtaran ng bawat isa sa mga iyon tingnan kung paano dito kung saan iginuhit ko ang natitirang dalawang solusyon ay ang ginawa ko lang ay baligtarin ang
mga kulay ngayon ang tanging problema ay ang algorithm ay hindi nahanap o natukoy ang ikaapat na huling solusyon bilang
isa sa mga nangungunang apat na pinaka-malamang na sagot ito ang ikalima ang ikaapat na solusyon na natukoy ng algorithm
ay talagang Mali at kung iguguhit mo ito ay makikita mo na ang solusyong iyon ay mayroon lamang apat na cut at dahil ang iba ay
may lima at ang apat ay malinaw na mas mababa sa lima ito ay malinaw na mali ang punto dito
ay ang ito ay isang approximate algorithm hindi ito mali-maling mawalan at hindi ito tama 100% ng oras kailangan mong
gumamit ng ilan sa iyong sariling kaalaman at pag-unawa para ma-sanity check ang mga solusyon kapaki-pakinabang na itampok na
ang error na ito ay maaaring lumabas mula sa ilang lugar maaaring ito ang approximate na katangian ng algorithm mismo at ang maliit
na bilang ng mga layer na pinili ko na gamitin maaaring ito ay isang finite sampling error at ito ay maaaring mabawasan kung pinapalaki ko ang
bilang ng mga shot sa aking eksperimento o maaaring ito ay isang readout error dahil ang ikaapat na tunay na solusyon ay isa lamang na bit ang pagkakaiba
ang dahilan ng aking pagbanggit ng lahat ng mga posibilidad na ito ay dahil ito ang kinakailangan para maging ganap
practitioner ng quantum Computing kailangan mong maunawaan ang pagganap ng hardware at kung paano ito maaaring mag-ambag
sa ilang mga uri ng error at kung paano ito iwasto gayunpaman huwag nating kalimutan na mayroon
32 posibleng bit string na solusyon at ang apat na tunay na solusyon ay kasama sa nangungunang lima
pinakamahusay na kandidato at dalawang layer lang ang ginamit ko para mahanap ito sa pangkalahatan kung gusto kong dagdagan ang aking mga pagkakataon na mahanap ang
pinakamahusay na Max cut sa bawat pagkakataon ay palalawakin ko ang layer depth may ilang subtlety dito ngunit iyon ay para sa ibang
episode ngayon ay pahahalagahan kong subukan mo ito nang ikaw mismo ngunit sa pagkakataong ito ay gagamitin mo ang 100
qubit kaya kung magsisimula tayo sa pamamagitan ng pagguhit ng aming 100 qubit graph makikita mo na hindi na ito tapat o kahit posible
na makita sa paningin kung saan mangyayari ang max cut masyadong maraming posibilidad para ma-pick out nang kamay ngunit
ang paglutas ng problemang ito gamit ang qaoa ay posible pa rin at maaari kang sumunod sa eksaktong parehong workflow na ginamit natin para sa 5
qubit nais ko na ikaw ay sarili mong magsimula at sinisisingil kita na subukan ang eksperimentong ito ngunit bago ko gawin ay
ibuod natin alalahanin na ang anim na hakbang ng anumang qaoa job ay ang mga sumusunod isa ang pagtukoy ng
isang cost hamiltonian na ang ground state nito ay nag-e-encode ng solusyon sa optimization problem dalawa ang pagtukoy ng isang
mixer hamiltonian tatlo ang pagtayo ng mga operator na katumbas ng exponentiated
hamiltonians apat ang pagtatayo ng circuit binubuo ito ng panimulang ground state ng mixer at alternating
paulit-ulit na mga layer ng cost function at ang ebolusyon sa ilalim ng mixer hamiltonians lima ang paghahanda ng isang paunang estado at
paggamit ng mga classical Computing technique para i-optimize ang mga parameter anim ang pagpapatakbo ng circuit pagsukat ng output bit strings
naghahanap ng pinaka-malamang na solusyon ngayon ang ilang bagay na dapat pansinin dito
ay ginamit ko ang optimization level tatlo para sa aking 5 qubit na halimbawa ngunit maaaring hindi iyon kinakailangan at ang tamang sagot ay maaari pa rin
maibalik nang madalas sa mas mababang antas ng optimization dahil ang circuit depth ay medyo mababa para sa 5
qubit na kaso ngunit para sa 100 qubit at isang malaking circuit depth ay halos tiyak na kakailanganin mo ang pinakamataas na antas ng
optimization para mahanap ang tamang sagot pati na rin ay tandaan na ang isa sa mga pinaka-mapaghamong bahagi ng isang tipikal na utility
scale workflow ay ang mapping stage at ang paghahanap ng isang graph na tumutugma nang maayos sa IBM's heavy hex topology kung
gagawin mo ang gawaing ito mula sa simula iyon nang walang alinlangan ay kung saan mo igugugol ang karamihan ng iyong oras sa ngayon ang bahaging ito ay
ginawa na para sa iyo dahil iyon ang pangunahing punto ng ehersisyong ito ngunit tandaan na ito ay isang bagay na
nangangailangan ng pagsasanay at ang pagpapatakbo ng isang malaking sukat na trabaho ay hindi palaging tapat ay mas malalim nating tatalakayin ito
sa episode 4 ang iyong huling circuit ay malinaw na magmumukhang higit na magulo kaysa sa circuit na tumakbo sa 5 qubit
ngunit sa kabilang banda ay naramdaman ko na ang pagtingin sa circuit na ito at pagkita kung gaano karaming gate ito at pag-alam na
mayroon kang kakayahan na talagang patakbuhin ito sa tunay na Quantum processors ay medyo
kahanga-hanga at ito ang aking huling solusyon makikita mo na ang algorithm ay tiyak na may kakayahang mag-grupo ng mga
node sa dalawang grupo na allegedly natutukoy ang pinakamahusay na Max cut na naghahati sa kanila mula sa pagpunta mula sa dalawang set
patungo sa max cut line mismo ay Trivial saan man nagbabago ang kulay kasunod ng mga linya na nagkokonekta sa mga node ay nagtatakda
kung saan dapat iguhit ang max cut line kapag pinatakbo ko ito ang max cut value na nagawa kong makamit ay
84 kaya subukan mo para sa iyong sarili at ipaalam sa akin kung nakakuha ka ng katulad sa mga comment subukan ang tatlong layer marahil apat subukan ang
pagbabago ng mga timbang sa pagitan ng mga node at tingnan kung paano nagbabago ang resulta may marami naming kawili-wiling eksperimento
na maaari nating patakbuhin gamit ang qaoa ngayon tandaan na hindi garantisado na kakagawa ko lang ng pinakamahusay na posibleng
solusyon alam nating ito ay isang magandang solusyon ngunit para sa kasiyahan ay hinihamong subukan mong talunin ako tingnan kung makakakuha ka ng isang bagay
na mas maganda kaysa sa 84 sa konklusyon ang qaoa ay isang napaka-dynamic
algorithm at marami pang heuristic at marami pa ring dapat tuklasin nagbibigay ito ng maraming puwang para matuto ng bago
mga bagay tungkol sa larangan ng optimization sa pangkalahatan ay nagkaroon ng maraming gawain kamakailan sa espasyo ng optimization tulad ng
ebidensya ng lahat ng mga archive paper na kamakailan ay nailathala online sa qaoa o optimization at kung ano ang
talagang kahanga-hanga ay ang sa wakas ay hindi lahat ng mga papel na ito ay mga teorya ang mga theorist ay nagtatrabaho at nag-aaral
ng qaoa sa loob ng maraming taon ngunit ngayon ang mga eksperimentalista ay nagsasangkot na dahil sa wakas ay mayroon na tayo ng hardware
tulad ng mga processor ng IBM na may kakayahang magpatakbo ng marami sa mga eksperimentong ito lumalipat tayo mula sa espasyo ng imahinasyon
patungo sa totoong mundo at iyon ay napaka-kapana-panabik oo mayroon pa ring maraming gawain na kailangang gawin at mayroon pa rin
napakaraming error na kailangan nating alamin kung paano harapin ngunit mabilis tayong nagtatayo ng pag-unlad at ikaw na nanonood ng
video kung nakarating ka sa ganito ay may kakayahang magpatakbo ng mga eksperimentong ito nang ikaw mismo pakisubukan ang pagpapatakbo ng iyong sariling
100 qubit na eksperimento at ipaalam sa amin kung paano nagpunta sundan ang tutorial at ikaw ay nasa mabuting kamay at kung
mayroon kang anumang mga katanungan o natigil huwag mag-alala lahat tayo ay naramdaman iyon o nagkaroon ng parehong mga katanungan nang una tayong nagsimulang
matuto nito gawin ang iyong pinakamahusay ipaalam sa amin kung anong mga katanungan ang iyong naranasan at magkita-kita tayo sa susunod na pagkakataon
[Musika]